quand myriam tibi pour moi vous êtes
moins sont en recrutement vous êtes une
maman célibataire de quatre filles c'est
ça vous avez fait une demande de
logement social à bagnolet ça on vous a
répondu
les juifs ça de l'argent à des lots
fondée sous aller dans une agence
immobilière
incroyable voilà donc j'ai porté plainte
d'accord et j'ai été soutenu par le
bnvca par le président monsieur sammy
ghozlan le bnvca c'est le bureau de
vigilance national contre
l'antisémitisme qui a remonté mon
dossier au préfet donc il ya eu une
enquête administrative
cet employé a été licencié et j'ai
obtenu mon logement par la préfecture il
paraît qu'à votre travail votre chef
vous a dit conte mais y at-il de juifs
ici c'est ça qui est juif
j'ai juste pour savoir qu'à les juifs
car les juifs réussissent tout à fait
j'ai travaillé pendant cinq ans dans une
agence d'intérim je vais pas citer le
nom parce que je suis en prud'hommes
bien sûr donc j'ai pas envie que ça se
retourne ça se retourne contre moi mais
oui il y a un nouveau chef de secteur se
présente et bungie à combien de juifs
dans la société qui sont les juifs
donc je suis un petit peu autres et je
savais pas qu'on est encore en france 9
45 où il fallait n'en prenne en compte
et voilà le nombre de juifs mais j'ai
été porté plainte j'ai fait un mail à
mon responsable j'ai été porté plainte
le 9 décembre je reçois une lettre
remise en main propre pour un
licenciement et le 18 décembre je suis
licencié pour quel motif
pour l'instant on me dit j'ai rajouté un
plongeur en plus j'ai une espèce je n'ai
pas scanner un dossier des futilités
je suis première un recrutement sur 101
alors vous dites que vous avez peu
employée modèle
voilà vous avez peur du climat
antisémite actuelle tout à vous dites
que votre quartier a complètement changé
moi il va vous habitez où j'habite à
bagnolet d'accord mais j'ai toujours
vécu dans des quartiers populaires avril
à avoir quelques garrido comme maire à
calgary noël est bien gentil mais on la
voit jamais sur bagnolet
voilà où la boisson mais pas alors vous
allez l'avoir beaucoup en ce moment
puisque l amérique d'ailleurs elle
embrasse des oracles et jean tiff c'est
vrai voilà à quelques et pas avec nous
pendant quelques semaines puisque
forcément comme se présente à bagnolet
voilà on peut voit pas ne pouvait pas
être autour de la table ce soir il faut
soit être sur la ville à temps complet
alors pourquoi vous dites que ça a
changé
qu'est ce qui se passe au jour ce qui se
passe c'est que moi j'ai grandi
personnellement dans des quartiers
populaires romainville et lille à
bagnolet
ça fait trop sur bagnolet et on voit
vraiment la ville se dégrader tout ce
qui est seine saint denis ça se dégrade
une fois parce que c'est la nouvelle
génération des réseaux sociaux où on
essaye de monter les uns contre les
autres et surtout où l'antisémitisme est
aggravée voilà tout ce qui est saine ça
vous fait peur ça oui ça me fait très
peur mais vous êtes quand même quelques
chiffres si je peux vous coupez le
chiffre de ministères de la sorte de la
de la justice en 2019
il ya eu 1142 crimes racistes donc dont
687 incidents antisémites
les juifs de france représente 1% de la
population
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un gros
problème c'est + 27 % d'actifs en
évolution alors on est allé en plein
coeur de paris
poser des questions aux français à
propos de la communauté juive et son
histoire dans un premier temps leur a
demandé pour eux en trois mots ce que
représentait les juifs et combien ils
sont en france
regardez alors juifs en train de très
bonnes questions et l'antisémitisme et
les gosses argentin cacher leur argent
pouvoir argent asie directement excuse
moreau et à hitler communaux des sujets
de société
religion sont intelligents
mais je trouve qu'elle a un peu trop
mais bon combien de juifs à francine a
beaucoup on va dire il
10 % de la population en portant la
population française je dirais les 10000
20%
voyez un peu moins de 1% des juifs en
france 1% - ils sont quatre cent
soixante mille c'est tout mais c'est pas
poli si ça nous fait rire mais c'est
servir un sketch c'est incroyable c'est
vrai qu'on ne devrait pas regarder ça
vous avez raison mais mine de rien on
dira ce qu'est tient myriam vous avez
tout à fait raison
et oui il ya environ 468 juifs en france
il représente moins de 1% de la
population dans un second temps la
demande et aux passants ce qui était la
shoah et combien de juifs sont décédés
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale
regarde et c'est compliqué comme
question je suis né tout de suite après
on en parle beaucoup et que pas beaucoup
de gens connaissent dont moi c'est vrai
la shoah c'est l'extermination
je pense plus
ce n'est pas plus je cherchais pas c'est
pas des millions de juifs qui ont été
massacrés pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
cent mille à un million de juifs
peut-être deux je sais plus combien
l'avortement il veut tricher il veut
tricher touche r je l'avais en tête la
cime il ya les 33 dès l'avènement du
troisième reich et qui a quand même tué
six millions de juifs ce crime contre un
peuple au motif que c'est ce peuple là
voilà donc entre cinq à six millions de
juifs sont décédés bien sûr donc c'est
vrai que c'est incroyable ces micro
trottoir c'est censé être dans les
manuels scolaires
bien sûr mais non par les manuscrits et
ça ne l'est pas alors à dans toutes les
villes en tout cas